Why don't we get started.
It's 9:00 AM.
So good morning everyone, and I guess if you're
on the east coast, good afternoon.
I'm Alex Bui, co-director of the BD2K Center's
coordination center.
And so last week we had a wonderful kick off
to section two of our fundamentals to data
science web seminars where we're now talking
about data representation issues.
We have an overview of some of the challenges
that was given by Dr. Bandrowski of UC San
Diego.
So in today's talk we're going to go a bit
deeper now on some of the key ideas and issues
in the organization of big data, focusing
primarily on the databases and repositories
we use to manage and combine information.
So we'll be getting a perspective on the evolution
of databases, and how they're changing to
handle big data.
So it's my pleasure to actually introduce
two people who will be speaking to us today
on this topic.
So our first speaker is Dr. Chaitanya Baru
of National Science Foundation.
Dr. Baru is the senior advisor for data science
in NSS science directory where he coordinates
the Cross Foundation Big Data Research Program
and co-chairs the Big Data Interagency Working
Group.
Our second speaker is Dr. Elena Zheleva.
She is a computer scientistic with a background
in machine learning, social network analysis,
and online privacy.
Dr. Zheleva is a science and technology policies
fellow at the American Association for the
Advancement of Science at NSF where she's
involved in a number of big data and data
science inititiatives.
Dr. Baru and Zheleva, we're delighted to have
you with us, and so without further ado, let's
get started.
Dr. Baru.
All right, good morning, good afternoon.
Can you hear me OK, Alex?
Yes, we can.
All right, so I'm also assuming that you're
seeing our slides.
So actually what we'd like to do, this is
going to be a joint presentation between Elena
and myself.
And as you heard, Elena is more on the machine
learning side of big data, and my background
is more on the data management side.
So she gets started talking about some of
the more interesting machine learning kinds
of things that people have been doing now
with all sorts of interesting data that out
there.
And then I'll try to give a little bit more
perspective on the data management side.
So if you're seeing our first slide, basically
it talks about technologies like databases,
data warehouses, and in today's talk, when
we talk about databases-- most of us are computer
scientists, as you heard-- we'll be talking
about a little bit more from the technical
meaning of databases rather than sort of any
community repository.
So there's a generic use of the term database
that currently reference to any sort of managed
data, but we'll be a little bit more technical
about that.
And in the process, we'll try to cover some
of the issues of structures, types and integrations.
One way to think about what we will talk about
today is maybe-- at least in some aspects
of it-- maybe more of a computer science view
of some of the issues that you heard Anita
talk about in the last presentation.
So let's see.
Yeah.
Hopefully, you're seeing our second slide.
So that's the two of us, Elena and myself.
Going further, the outline.
And then I will talk about some of the data
science task examples, the kind of things
we like doing.
And what we decided during this presentation,
in one hour, we have to give you a very quick
tour of all the things going on.
So I'm going to take a sort of historical
view of data management, where we started
and where we are.
And when we get there, I'll say why we are
trying to do that.
I'll talk about some of the current technologies,
and then in a way, where things are going
and some of the take-home messages.
So let's get started with Elena, who's right
here.
Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
So this is a lecture series on the fundamentals
of data science.
I thought it would be helpful to give you
a data scientist perspective on why today's
topic is important in the process of doing
data science.
And while you don't necessarily need to understand
all the technology details of the data management
solutions out there, as a data scientist,
you do need to have a good idea when to use
one solution versus another.
So first, I will give you some typical scenarios
that data scientists face.
Imagine that you're interested in one of these
three research questions listed on this slide.
For example, how do new research topics emerge?
How do kids use playgrounds?
How can you create more secure code?
There are many different approaches that you
can take to answer these questions.
But given that we live in the age of big data,
I will reformulate these questions specifically
to take advantage of large, publicly-available
datasets.
So the first question was about how new research
topics emerge.
Network scientists may approach this problem
by studying citation networks.
More specifically, which articles reference
which other articles, and how research topics
propagated through these articles over time.
And as most of you know, one large data source
of publication citations is PubMed.
PubMed currently contains over 26 million
articles, and probably an order of magnitude
more reference bearers, or which articles
cite which other articles.
So as you can see, this is already a problem
that can be solved through a lot of data.
The second research question that I presented
was one that a behavioral scientist might
be interested in, about how kids use playgrounds.
And more specifically, the angle on this question
that I'm taking here is what do user-generated
videos on playgrounds tell us about how kids
use playgrounds?
So for example, in September this year, Google
released a data set for research purposes
from YouTube which contains 8 million videos
and around 1.5 terabytes of data.
And each video is actually tagged by the entities
that are included in the different frames
of the video.
And you can actually search by entity.
So for example, if I search for playground,
I can find that this dataset contains 255
videos of playgrounds.
That's great.
255 videos is not a lot of data, right?
It's only 255.
However, for you to extract these videos and
do an analysis on these videos, you need to
download the full 1.5 terabytes of data and
find these videos in order to do analysis
on them.
The third research question that I presented
was about how to create more secure code.
And it's a question that security researchers
might be interested in.
The specific angle that we can take on it
is what you can learn from version updates
of code repositories in order to create more
secure code.
And there's an example here I would like to
give, Github.
Github is very popular too amongst software
developers, and it currently contains over
38 million repositories.
Moreover, Google actually made 2.8 million
of these repositories available for querying
through BigQuery.
And this is already over 3 terabytes of data.
And here, I'm just giving a specific example
of a few such repositories that are related
to computational biology.
So all these three tasks actually require
processing large amounts of data.
And today, we're not going to talk about how
we're going to answer these questions.
But we will actually talk about how we can
process such data.
So when you answer research questions with
data, there are many different sources of
data that you may have access to.
Some of them may have structured data, others
semi-structured data, but the majority of
data out there falls in the category of unstructured
data.
Structured data is data that has a pretty
fine data model, such as data and relational
databases, and it is fairly straightforward
to query.
Semi-structured data is a type of structured
data where your schema is often contained
within the data itself.
And some examples include XML and JSON files.
Unstructured data does not have a pre-defined
data model, which makes them harder to query.
And some examples include scientific articles,
where you can have a mix of figures, algorithms,
and text, and where each article may have
different section structure.
So one may start with introduction and then
go on to algorithms, and another one may start
with an introduction and then jump into actual
data analysis.
So video data is another example where the
video frames do not follow this earlier pre-defined
data model.
And lastly, code repositories can have different
folders and file structures and end types.
Now that you know what kind of data you're
dealing with, you need to decide on where
you will store the data and
how you can query to answer your questions
of interest.
All three tasks that I described require you
to process large amounts of data, and there
are many solutions to storing and managing
large datasets that exist out there.
One can easily spend a lot of time exploring
and trying to decide on the best tool to use.
Do you use the latest tool?
Do you stick to using what you feel most comfortable
with?
And the answer is it depends.
Some of these tools provide a similar set
of capabilities.
Others are complementary to each other.
For example, if you're a software application
developer, you may store the data that your
application collects in a MySQL database.
But you may want to export it do a Hadoop
class or a cloud service in order to enable
fast analytics on it.
You may also want to use a Redis store for
the results from your analytics engine, so
that your application has fast access to your
analytical results.
Something that plays an important role in
deciding on the best tools to use for a specific
task is the characteristics of the data that
you're dealing with.
You need to take into consideration the volume
of the data, its variety and diversity, whether
it's streaming and at what speed, and also
what you plan to use the data for.
Whether it's an internal report that you need
to generate once a day, or whether it is to
produce analytical data that has to be made
available real time.
And today, instead of making specific recommendations
on which tools you should use, or talking
about low-level details of the technology
behind them, we would like to take you on
a journey in the history of databases and
how the different modern tools came to be
and why they're important.
Great.
Thanks, Elena.
So I'm going to then switch into sort of the
history mode.
And as I said, we sort of decided that we
might want to give you more of an overview
of the landscape of what's out there.
So if any of you are computer science people
or have been interacting with computer scientists,
especially with all the recent stuff going
on with big data and the whole focus on data,
you might have heard people talking about,
well, so what's new here?
Are we doing anything different, and how does
it relate to what we've already been doing?
So we thought we'd give you a perspective
on where we are coming from, which hopefully,
we'll understand where we are going.
So where we are today, and where we are going.
I think the take-home message-- which I actually
have a site on there at the end-- but to give
you right up front is, we are now in a situation
where there are a lot of choices available
to us.
That's good and bad.
I mean, it's bad in the sense that that means
you'll understand what your choices are and
make the right decisions, but it's good in
the sense that, depending on the kind of problem
you're tackling-- like you heard three different
examples-- you could actually choose different
solution methods.
And again, as I'll say at the end, some of
it may depend on how much freedom you have,
and are you doing it for yourself, or are
you in a
corporate context where maybe you don't have
as much control.
But anyway, let's launch into this.
One more thing I wanted to say before starting
is, I didn't actually spend a minute introducing
ourselves.
So just to reiterate, Elena's a [INAUDIBLE]
fellow here at NSF, but from next year she's
going to be on the faculty at the University
of Illinois, Chicago.
I'm here at NSF, as you heard, but I'm actually
here from the University of California in
San Diego.
So I'm a UCSD person, and I have a couple
of references our UCSD projects.
And as you heard last week from Anita Bandrowski,
who's also from UC San Diego.
OK, so if you think back to way back when,
fundamentally, what people were doing was
writing programs dealing with files.
And that actually takes us all the way back
to sort of the beginning of computing, so
the 1950s, 60s, where every time you thought
about a problem that you wanted to solve,
whether it's-- and by the way, another way
to think about the history also is, how many
people were doing this and where were they
doing it?
So in the early days, there actually were
very few people doing this kind of-- any kind
of computing.
And most of it was happening in corporate
settings.
So you can think about, in corporate settings,
people wanting to do inventory control, or
finance systems, or doing some kind computational--
something related to whether they were modeling
a physical process, or whatever.
Every activity started with your having to
write, essentially, an [INAUDIBLE] program.
And the program had to deal with its own data.
Now, that quickly moved into a setting where
there
was plenty of data, and you had to deal with
somehow making it more efficient.
So from literally flat files of data, people
invented new ways of getting more efficient
access to data.
That's what we call structured files.
Oh, sorry.
There you go.
And you move forward to the 60s and 70s, where
we have programming languages like EL1, COBOL,
things that many of you may not have heard
about.
Actually, some of those are probably still
running in old systems.
But basically, that was a world where you
were dealing with fairly slow hardware, and
disks were much slower than memory.
Today, disks are still slow, but there's a
much, much more fine hierarchy of storage
between disk and memory.
In those days, it was pretty simple.
There was either a disk or a memory.
And so you have to do something to bridge
across that.
And so then we come to a situation where we
have, therefore, application logic.
So remember that anything that you wanted
to do with data, you would have to write a
different program, right?
So you have the so-called application logic
encoded in those programs, and those programs
also hardwire the data that they are going
after.
And the kind of models that-- the situation
that people found themselves in was that multiple
different programs were creating the same
data over and over again.
So you might have multiple applications in
a corporate context that are all dealing with
employees for one reason or the other.
Maybe one is payroll, the other is benefits.
And they were all recreating this employee
information.
So the realization came that we're having
inconsistent data, and we are duplicating
data unnecessarily.
So that's sort of the start of thinking about
data as something separate from the application
that's working on the data.
And that's a very important concept in computer
science, is the abstraction concept that begins
to separate application logic from the data.
You can think of it very easily, that there's
a database, I can go and write SQL queries
and get all sorts of ad-hoc information [INAUDIBLE]
database.
That was not the case before, where the application
was very tightly tied to the kind of data
it was dealing with.
And multiple applications created the same
data, because there was really no sharing
going on.
And the reason I'm harping on that is some
of this may come back to us, and some of the
present world might look like that.
But you know, that's where we came from.
And we realized that we should separate those
out.
And there were these models called hierarchical
and network [INAUDIBLE] hierarchies that,
most obviously, you can think about organizing
information.
You have a corporation, you have departments,
you have people working in departments.
That sounds hierarchical.
Or you have a human.
Humans have different organs, and then you
can organize the human system as a bunch of
different organ systems, and that sounds like
a hierarchy.
Well, soon, what happens is, you might say--
or think about courses, right?
So you have courses in a university.
Courses have offerings.
I offer a course this fall, next spring, et
cetera.
Each offering has students.
But what if you wanted to ask a question that's
says, for each student, tell me all the teachers
that are interacting with that student.
That becomes a very difficult query to answer
if it's hierarchical in nature, because you
have to sort of go up the hierarchy, find
out for each person who is the-- which course
they're in, and then for that course, who's
the teacher.
So when people found that there are inefficiencies
here, the network model was created, which
would say, well, maybe for these students,
I should just make pointers to all the teachers,
if i'm asking this query very often, about
what are the set of teachers teaching the
student.
But as you think about more and more such
queries that you want to do, the structure
becomes very complicated.
So that led to the need for people to think
about, what is a more abstract way in which
we can represent this information, so that
any query, more or less, could be equally
well answered, and not just stuffed with our
hardcoded into the database.
And that leads to this model that we now have,
is the relational model, where we say, let's
store all information in tables.
And there is some theory behind how we develop
these tables, and how we make sure that we
are not repeating information.
So we remove replication.
We increase the consistency of the database.
And that's our relational databases.
And that's when we realize that the notion
of a database, now, in computer science, then,
is that there is something called a data model,
which is a formal definition of how data is
represented.
And then there is actually a formal query
language that we can build on top of it.
So relationally, this is a kind of set-oriented
data models.
There are relations.
There are dependencies among columns in a
relation, and between relations.
And then we can define the formal algebra,
which ends up being embodied in SQL.
And also, by then, the kinds of things we
were doing with data were of two types.
One was what you would call transactions.
Again, this in a corporate context where data
is coming in, data is being updated.
You might be doing purchases.
You might be at a bank.
You're doing bank transactions.
So there's a whole set of technologies related
to transaction processing that are essentially
doing insertions, deletions, updates on data.
And then there's a whole set of things about
doing queries.
And remember, in the old days, it was about
writing.
For each query you wanted to do, you literally
had to write a program.
So the technology was, well, can we do common
technology that can support both?
So transaction processing versus query processing.
And I would say from around the 1980s onward
when the relational model came up, the idea
was, let's use one system to do it all, and
which ended up being a success.
Relational model, when it started, was not
viewed as that it might be successful.
There were all sorts of issues, because it
was, in a way, slow to begin, compared to
existing technologies.
But a lot of work was done to make it more
efficient.
And as it became successful, it sort of became
the thing that everybody wanted to use to
store data.
So then you got into these problems where
people said, as you heard earlier, that the
data was getting more complex.
People wanted to store more things, like images
or strings, or even videos.
So people wanted to store objects that were
more than what a standard database would support.
Typical database might support your basic
data types, like integers.
Oops, sorry.
I apologize.
There's some interruption going here.
OK.
I think I'm back.
So the question was, how do you support objects
in this?
And as we move to the 90s, we are also talking
about more object-oriented programming, so
objects in C++ and Java.
And the other was the need to support, say,
things like text, video, images.
And this is the start of the first time we
started seeing this notion of variety.
In this case, it's a variety of different
objects that are stored in the same database.
And this is because the success by then of
the relational model meant that everybody
wanted to use that as the one stop shop for
data management.
But then it starts putting stress on the technology,
right?
So as we move forward from there, we also
get to the place where we are putting more
and more data in these systems, and more and
more people are using data.
Remember, we started by saying there were
not that many people actually using computing.
And of course, by the 80s and 90s, this is
all over the place.
So there's a lot more data that's being generated
that has to be managed, and the question was,
how do we build efficient systems to do that?
So by the mid 90s, we had, so far, parallel
database systems.
And these were still using the relational
model, still supporting SQL, which is very
popular by then.
By then providing ways of processing all that
in parallel, and there's a big sort of industry
around that to support big clusters and parallel
computing on SQL databases.
But then we come to a situation where, especially,
the internet web-scale companies like the
Googles and Facebooks have arrived on the
scene, and they are seeing even more data.
So this is even more volume from them.
And actually, along with that also goes the
speed at which the data is arriving.
So there's also a problem of [INAUDIBLE] streams,
and a lot what we would call the velocity.
And in a way, I don't know if you can call
it abandoned, but those companies realized
that the relational technology that had built
up over the years, over the decades, was a
little bit complicated to use for these extremely
large data.
It does take a while to put your data in,
to structure it.
And also, in these cases, the data was not
structured.
It had this sort of semi-structured characteristic
to it, because a lot of it was social media
data coming in through websites or weblog
data which was not wellstructured.
So that brings us systems like Hadoop, which
are massively parallel and very robust, for
the level of parallelism they have.
So literally, you're talking about thousands
of nodes of computers running, and there's
a robustness across it.
Because in some sense, you can say it was
a very simple model that was implemented that
ensured that the overall system was very robust.
And that's enhanced by the fact that hardware
was relatively cheap, and we had to really
literally deal with terabytes of data that
we are now seeing in many different domains.
That also meant that the implementations had
to be simpler.
You couldn't support the real complexity that
SQL had agglomerated by then.
I mean, by this time, SQL is almost like a
full programming language.
You couldn't really implement all of that
on massive terabyte systems.
So all of a sudden, the language became simpler.
And so you started hearing more things like
noSQL, which was meant to be simple SQL in
the beginning, and now
people called it all sorts of different things,
including not only SQL, because the interesting
trend that's happening- that has happened
already in the Hadoop, these massively parallel
systems-- is SQL is coming back.
People are now implementing more and more
of SQL on top of these systems.
So this is where back to the future kind of
feeling comes back, and that's why we wanted
to take you through this history as to try
and make sense of all the stuff that's going
on.
So we started with simple query languages,
noSQL.
Because people realize that, even with those
terabyte systems, there are some very basic
things you should be able to do, like filtering
data out, doing simple aggregations-- what
in SQL you might call group by-making aggregates
on certain attribute values, maybe a date
value, maybe the name of a person, whatever
it is.
So simple aggregation is very important.
And that brings you back into this world of
having some sort of query language on top.
At the same time, there's all this essentially
unstructured stuff going on that Elena mentioned,
and things like JSON become very popular,
and all the web stuff becomes popular.
So people wanted to take things that they
are creating in their programming languages
and dump it straight into database.
So these systems have been required to support
things like JSON now as a data model.
So we have databases like Cassandra, and all
of those-- sorry, many of those-- and noSQL
databases are going into that semi-structured
mode, and not necessarily the full relational
model.
Now, relational model has not gone away.
So this is where your menu of options increase.
So you still have the relational model.
You have pure Hadoop, if you want, really.
Or you could have SQL on top of Hadoop, or
you could have JSON.
So this is where all the choices keep increasing.
And finally, I think where we are right now
is, if we are looking at it from a corporate
point of view, and also increasingly as individual
scientists, as we are solving more complex
problems, we want to deal with many sources
of data.
It's not just necessarily-- there's clearly
a whole group of problems, including maybe
in things like next generation sequencing
and so on, when there's one data type-- maybe
it's the genome sequence, or it's the social
media interaction graph-- that you're trying
to mine and learn more from.
Or maybe it's just videos.
But they're also now increasing-- we have
more problems where you want to put multiple
different datasets together.
Maybe you want to put census together with
electronic health records, et cetera.
And that brings us to this world of very heterogeneous
data sources.
And one concept that has now emerged is this
notion of a data lake.
I'm going to say a little bit more about that.
But essentially, it's the idea that you can
dump all sorts of different data into one
place.
It's loosely structured, and that's the sort
of analogy to a lake.
But at least it's all in one place, and you
can do something with it.
So that's the full circle we've come around.
Remember, we started in the 50s and 60s, and
here we are now.
So we want to say
a little bit more about some of these concepts
and where we might be going.
So let's talk a little bit about this idea
of data warehouses versus data lakes.
So data warehouses started probably in the
late 80s to the 90s, when people had already
rationalized their data systems into relational
databases, or whatever, so they had reduced
the redundancy in data.
But what they didn't realize is that there
were multiple different databases, even within
a large company.
It could be geographic regions.
Maybe they had a division in Europe and a
division in the US, or the east coast and
west coast had their own data.
Or the finance guys had one set of coherent
datasets, and the sales guys had a difference
set of coherent datasets.
And when people wanted to do decision support
inside such a system, they had to bring all
of these data together.
So the data warehouse is really the concept
that, if you want to get a more holistic view
of whatever it is that you're looking at,
you do have to bring data from different places
together.
And that led to this creation of warehouses.
So the data warehouses started at that time
when people said, oh, you know what?
These data are not just about transactions.
Another thing to remember is, a lot of the
roots of data management community actually
do come from industry.
Because interestingly, that's where data started
initially, where the boom of data.
The science folks were doing their own little
thing, and they were not really using these
technologies.
And if you come back to today, this is also
where big data started, was actually back
in industry.
Because, again, they just had the imperative
to deal with the data, and they had to do
something about it.
So the data warehouses were the situation
where the business said, all of this data
that we are collecting, can we do something
more with it in terms of messaging support
and strategy?
So what they realized when they started putting
that together is that there was some diversity
in the way that the different databases were
being created, even if it was within one enterprise,
one big company, or whatever.
And that led to some heterogeneity.
And so when you put all of this stuff back
together-- and let's say you're trying to
get one common view of your customer, but
there may be a slightly different view of
the customer in the finance database, and
a slightly different view in the sales database--
this is where you have to start generating
metadata to say things like, OK, what we are
calling a customer ID over there is something
else ID over here.
So data warehouses are typically associated
with being heavily cleaned up in that way,
having metadata.
And there are a lot of rules about what can
get into a data warehouse and what doesn't
get in, so that when you use it,
it's a very sort of a clean dataset.
And if you've dealt with any data, you know
that cleaning up data is a big, big task,
and you might have to make some difficult
decisions about what goes in and what doesn't
go in.
The flip side of it, the data lake is kind
of the opposite.
You put everything in.
You can imagine that structuring, cleaning,
and putting stuff into a data warehouse implies
that there is some time and effort involved,
and also implies that there may be some delay
involved.
That is, from the time that you actually received
the data-wherever you might have got it--
in your operational system, till the time
it gets into the data warehouse, there's a
delay.
Therefore, when you're querying your warehouse,
you may not be getting the latest, greatest
data that the corporation might have.
So lakes were trying to solve that problem
to say, look, there are some applications
where I just need the latest data.
Even if it's dirty, I'm going to deal with
it.
So remember, you may be back to the situation
where you might be writing individual applications
that are working with the data lake, but you're
having to do it just because you want to get
the current status, and you're not happy that's
something that's one quarter old, or even
a month old, or even maybe a week old.
So that's kind of the difference between these
two environments.
Data warehouses are [INAUDIBLE] a single consistent
store of data, but they require you to transform
and ingest the data into a warehouse.
There's a notion of a star schema.
OK, let's see.
For this image, it shows that you're getting
data from different sources.
There is some step of so-called integration
you have to do, which is all the cleaning
up and the rationalization, before you can
put it into a warehouse.
So there is work involved there, but then
it enables a lot of different applications.
The notion of a schema is-- the reason you
create data warehouses like this is in order
to get this holistic view.
It's the holistic view of some entity that
you care about.
So typically, it could be a customer, if you're
a company, or it could be a patient.
It could be an individual, if you are dealing
with health care or public health, right?
So that thing that you care about is sort
of referred to as the fact, that fact has
many dimensions associated with it.
So that's this idea of a star.
So for example, we might care about a person
and a person's health and wellbeing.
And a person might have different dimensions
like their sickness record, which is essentially
the electronic health record.
Every time they got sick, there is some entry
in the EHR.
But we could also have something about their
activity, their food habit, where they have
they traveled, what's their family information.
So those would all be the dimensions.
And to push on that analogy a little further,
there is also this notion of a snowflake schema.
That is, each of those dimensions itself might
have a little bit of a structure.
But these are the kind of things that we deal
with when we talk about a data warehouse.
I won't look too much into this slide, but
it sort of repeats what I said before.
There are governance issues involved.
Governance, by the way, is a word that's coming
back today in today's sort of data-driven
world, as people realize that they really
want to use data to make decisions, whether
it's a serious scientific discovery or a corporation
making some strategic decisions.
And governance, then, is important, because
you need to know things like provenance.
You need to know, where did this data come
from?
What did we do with this data?
So just as an aside, the federal government
has started something called the-- it's actually
called the Federal Data Cabinet, but it's
a collection of all the chief data officers
across federal agencies.
And now there are about 125 or so people in
that group.
And I sit in on that just representing NSF,
and one of the first things-- first groups--
they started was a group that was going to
look at governance.
And [INAUDIBLE] your first step in governance
is to figure out, what are the data assets
that we have?
And your next step is to say, well, what can
we say about the quality of these assets,
right?
So data governance is an important thing,
and warehouses really do focus a lot on that.
But they are not good for unstructured data.
There is latency between when the data comes
into an organization and when it gets into
a data warehouse, for all the reasons we just
mentioned.
So data lakes, in a sense, are trying to address
that.
And data lake is a new-- relatively new--
concept.
It's a relatively new thing.
Depending on who you talk to, people will
either say, well, that's a very important
thing, or others will say, this is a waste
of time, or we're just revisiting other stuff.
And there's now the word data swamp, which
refers to, if you put all sorts of data into
one place, is it really useful?
We are just creating a swamp of data.
So there are all these issues.
But the problem is really-- and by the way,
and a lot of these data lakes are built on
top of this Hadoop technology, which is a
highly scaleable technology.
Because the point of data lakes is you want
to throw all your data into it, and you want
to start doing some easy analytics.
And as you heard before, a lot of the analytics
may be going off to unstructured data.
They may not be in relational databases.
You may actually be writing a program or a
script of some sort that wants to deal with
sort of relatively unstructured flat files,
really.
And so it's back to the flat file world, and
the lakes support that.
OK, so data lakes are increasingly also going
towards this notion of some structuring of
data within the lake.
And some of the ideas you will see that corporations
are embracing there is this notion of a [INAUDIBLE].
So your data may come and land in some landing
zone where it's all non-clean, whatever data
you've collected.
And there may be a sequence of steps that
it goes through, and that creates this sort
of workflow process.
That's actually a useful thing, because then
you might have different applications that
might say, you know what, I'm willing to go
after the dirty, dangerous data.
Or another location might say, I'm going to
go after data in stage three, after the screening
has been done.
So at least in creates the opportunity, rather
than having to say, well, you can't do anything
until all the data is cleaned up.
So there are some positives to it, but you
have to be a little bit careful in how you're
creating these kinds of assets.
So now let me flip to a project.
Turns out it's a project that UC San Diego
that I've been involved in, and not so much
involved in the last couple of years, since
I've come to NSF.
It's actually led by our fearless leader there,
Kevin Patrick, who is in population and public
health at UC San Diego.
There are other-- so almost half the team
is from the med school.
They have Ted Chan, who actually heads the
Beacon Project in San Diego, for those of
you know what the Beacon initiative.
It's just trying to integrate data from all
sorts of different DHR and other systems.
[INAUDIBLE] is our bioinformatics person.
But the other half of the project is computer
scientists.
So Yannis and Sanjoy and so on are professors
in computer science.
And the idea that we had here was, in a sense,
what warehouses and lakes are trying to do.
That is, in order to look at the whole information
related to an individual, the whole of the
health information, you need to put together
data from different sources.
And of course, there are many projects that
have been doing it, are doing it, and will
continue to do it.
But our idea in this project was, can we try
to standardize some of this, so that we don't
have to repeat the same thing again and again?
A lot of people are trying to do the same
thing, and trying to put together, maybe,
activity data with DHR data with pollution
data.
Let's try to see if we can make common APIs,
common processes, so that others don't have
to repeat that.
So that's basically the idea, and we came
up with this notion of a whole health information
model, and an API facilitated that.
And I just wanted to mention that because
this is a classic example of trying to integrate
very heterogeneous data.
It has semi-structured sources in there.
It has structured sources in there.
I don't think, initially, we were going after
any text or unstructured or even video, but
you know, that might be one of the things
we might put in there.
What it's trying to do is integrate information
from very different layers.
So as Kevin likes to point out, it's not about
just integrating information inside a hospital
or inside a clinical setting.
It's actually about integrating all the health
information related to a person, some of which
may from a hospital, but a lot of it has to
do with behavioral and environmental.
And if you really think in terms of the whole
health, that, in some ways, could be a lot
more important than just your disease and
sickness record.
So anyway, that's sort of the goal of that
project.
And so, flipping back to the kinds of data
that we'll encounter, as Elena said before,
we are not going to get into the details,
but we are trying to give you sort of a quick
survey of things.
So coming back to this notion of structured,
semi-structured, and so-called unstructured,
what do we mean by that?
From a computer science point of view, I said
that earlier.
Already we think of a database as something
that's structured, as the notion of a data
model is a formal specification of the data
and a query language that allows you to query
that.
Actually, another important thing that relational
databases do have is this notion of integrating
constraints.
And they are very important in order to make
sure that your data is clean.
So a simple integrated constraint could be
that Social Security number is a unique number.
You can't have two people with the same Social
Security number.
Another constraint could be that, if somebody
is working in a department, the name of that
department should exist, right?
So you couldn't be working in a department
that doesn't exist.
So that led to the [INAUDIBLE] characteristics
that are associated with structured databases,
referred to as ACID, [INAUDIBLE], Consistency,
Isolation, Durability.
These are all essentially transaction properties
that make sure that everything you do with
the database results in a correct state of
the database, that you can't do transactions
and queries on a database and mess up the
database.
And so the database ensures that that doesn't
happen.
We won't go into the details of each of those
technical things, but that's an important
concept.
Because we are back to this sort of [INAUDIBLE]
wireless world, as we've said before, with
noSQL, JSON, some of which will have this
notion of relaxed consistency-- you might
see the term-- where it's not necessarily
always true that the database is consistent,
and therefore, applications have to be very
careful that they may be encountering data
that's not completely clean.
And again, sometimes the reason they relax
those constraints is in order to be able to
deal with either the volume of the data or
the rate of the data.
If you're dealing with data that's coming
in very fast, you may not just have enough
time to make sure that it's all consistent,
and so on.
So it's useful to know that we're back to
the world where we're breaking some of the
rules that we had before.
So in structured databases, everything looks
very regular, like in a relational database.
All rows have the same format, et cetera.
Now, semi-structured databases-- as was mentioned,
an example would be XML-- they allow for a
little bit-- actually, for ad hoc structures.
So if you think about a bibliography at the
end of an article, it would have all sorts
of things in it, like papers, books, all sorts
of the other things.
And each of those might have a slightly different
structure, and you may not want to bend over
backwards and try
to put all the data into a relational database.
A semi-structured model makes a lot of sense
there.
A lot of web pages have that kind of structure,
right?
Even if the content in the web page nowadays
may come from a database of some sort, the
[INAUDIBLE] structured itself maybe better
represented as a semi-structured.
So I won't go into the syntax details, et
cetera.
Just quickly, most of the trends where we
are going, it turns out, as we represent more
and more complex information, whether it's,
say, cellular interactions or human interactions,
graphs are a very important type of data.
And now on the technology side, people are
beginning to build systems that efficiently
support graph data.
So one of the things we do with graph data--
it's still useful to be able to query a graph,
right?
So I can say, get me all the nodes in this
graph that have certain properties.
But other things you do with graphs are traversing
the graph.
We might want to find the shortest path between
x and y, and the path might represent some
connections between cells in the brain.
[INAUDIBLE] you heard about the neuroscience
information facility last time.
They do a lot of those kinds of things.
Graphs may also represent semantic linkages
for [INAUDIBLE] ontologies between terms.
So there are a lot of cases where graphs turn
up, and graph data is increasingly a very
important kind of data, might end up dominating
big parts of some of the applications.
That's the graph of, actually, my LinkedIn
network.
And we're also moving towards this notion
of creating knowledge graphs so that we can
build in the semantics and understand the
meanings of the terms that we are referring
to and the relationships between them.
And I think you have heard about these concepts
in some of the other talks, and probably will
hear more.
This is clearly-- there is something called
Semantic PubMed, where people are trying to
extract the semantics of the articles and
make those connections between articles based
on the meaning of the stuff, rather than just
the specific words.
Another trend that's rapidly approaching--
and my own view is, in future, we'll think
of everything as a stream, except some streams
will be much slower than others-- is data
streams.
And that's because the rate at which data
is coming at us, regardless of what the source
of data is, is just growing more and more.
And so everything starts looking like just
a sequence of stuff.
And examples right now are things like log
files on a computer, e-commerce purchases,
what people call click streams, when you're
clicking on a website, game information, information
from social networks.
Twitter tweets are all streamed, and so on.
And so there's a lot of this going on, and
there are new technologies that are being
developed.
One of the ones-- this is just one example--
is from Amazon, called Kinesis, that allows
you to sort of capture the stream of stuff
coming in.
And here, the example is mobile phones.
But the project that I've been working on
with
Kevin Patrick-- actually, there are a couple
of other projects that I didn't mention involving
M.D.
Anderson Cancer Center-- is where we are putting
sensors on people, whether it's smartphones
or other kinds of sensors, and measuring various
body parameters.
And those are all coming in as streams, and
there's going to be more and more of that,
as I'm sure you're all familiar with.
And then at the end of it, that data would
go into all sorts of different storage.
And that sort of S3, Redshift, Amazon Elastic
Search are all, again, different ways of storing
this.
So like we said before, your menu of options
are many right now.
So finally some take-home messages.
So when you're looking at the data, each of
us as individuals might be focused on one
aspect of it, but really, every piece of data
has a lifecycle.
And increasingly, we have to worry about it.
How was it collected, where did it come from,
and where is it going to end up?
And people are very concerned nowadays, and
especially in academia, we think of a paper
as the ultimate goal.
The ultimate goal really should be the data
that's related with the paper, and where does
the data end up?
So until that data has ended up somewhere
safely, we shouldn't say that your work is
done.
By just publishing a paper, it shouldn't be
the end of it.
Performance.
I mean, speaking as computer people, and I
know that Anita mentioned something about
this last time, that computer scientists care
a lot about performance.
Yes, we do, making things go fast.
That's what I mean.
And actually, going fast can be a game changer,
right?
Just think about it.
If every little data step that you had to
do took whatever, that will completely change
how you do your data analysis.
If things go very fast, it's a big enabler.
So computer science is always focused on how
to make it work faster and faster.
Other take-home messages.
In the world of data science, there are a
lot of different problems, and it really goes
back to the lifecycle question, everything
from cleaning to prediction.
And there are all these tools you can use
along the way.
So increasingly, you're in an environment
where you can actually use the right data
management tool for the right job.
It just means you need to have some awareness
of what is available, but also what might
you be giving up, if you pick one option versus
the other?
So what does it buy you?
And then finally, of course, there is the
context issue.
Is it something you're just doing by yourself?
You're doing it in a lab, in an institution
context, maybe a community, which may either
give you more options or may restrict what
you can do.
So that's just sort of the big picture.
The last thing I wanted to say is something
that we've been looking at here in the world
of science.
So if you think about the agenda of data as
it's going to grow into the future, data is
going to be more and more important to us
everywhere in our lives, right?
And there's going to be a lot of decisions,
whether we make them or some automated device
or a robot makes them.
It will all be data-driven.
So here, I'm starting with an example of just
computer science, our own discipline.
In computer science itself, there are areas
in CS that are becoming more data-intensive.
So there's more and more data available to
do research in computer science.
An example would be internet traffic.
There's a whole network research community
in computer science that researches internet
traffic and tries to understand what's going
on on the internet by looking at that traffic.
The amount of traffic is just tremendously
growing, obviously.
Another one is data center logs.
Increasingly, we have these massive data centers
with lots of computers, and you can actually
look at the logs that have all sorts of information
about the performance, the temperature, et
cetera.
And actually, you can use that to optimize
energy consumption and all sorts of other
things.
So there is an example just in computer science
of data coming at us and us having to deal
with it to do better computer science research.
Now, we happen to think that data science--
and actually engineering, which is a very
important part related to data-- is a thing
unto itself.
I mean, it's almost like a discipline to itself,
is data science and engineering, which has
its own theories.
And [INAUDIBLE], for example, just released
a solicitation for developing the principles
of data science.
And there are issues like data representation,
and we mentioned some of that today.
Modeling, whether statistical modeling or
representation modeling, machine learning,
decision support, reproducibility, I think
all of those together from the sort of discipline
of data science and engineering.
And our idea is that there is a translational
aspect, which is the aspect of taking all
these principles and theories of data science
and applying it to real-world problems.
And that application, there is some analogy
to this notion of translational medicine,
where you're taking about taking research
results and applying it in a clinical context.
Really, what all of us-- many of us, at least--
do with data is its clinical context of data,
right?
We are using data in the real world, and we
are thinking what techniques should I use
on that data?
That's translational stuff.
And so there are obviously data-intensive
everything going on.
There's biology, geoscience, medicine, and
so on.
So we see an opportunity here to think about--
a lot of what's actually being done there
is really translational work, and we are trying
to pursue that idea little bit further here
at NSF.
And I think that's it.
There's a few more minutes for questions.
Great.
Thank you so much, Drs.
Baru and Zheleva.
That was a great talk.
So we have one question from the audience
at this point, which is about the data lake
and the data warehouse.
So the question is, can data be put into the
data lake and into the data warehouse at the
same time as it's being prepared for the data
warehouse?
And could you comment a little bit about potential
parallel sort of framework?
Yes.
That's a good question.
And in a sense, the answer, I guess, is a
qualified yes, only in the sense that, like
I said, the data warehouse is definitely very
prescriptive.
Things can't go into the data warehouse unless
they meet a certain set of conditions.
That's sort of the notion of a warehouse.
As we said, a lake, you could more or less
dump anything in there.
But we also said that in a data lake, people
are now beginning to actually talk about phases
of the data.
So the data could go through multiple phases
of structuring and cleaning.
So it could be that at some point in that
process, the data has reached a level of cleanliness,
let's say, that your data warehouse would
say, OK, I can accept that.
And then you would do it.
And the reason to do it is-- data warehousing,
by the way, is a big industry, probably multiple
billion dollars.
So there are a lot of good tools, querying
tools, analysis tools, as well as visualization
tools for your data.
So you may want to actually use all of those
things, whereas data lake is still a little
bit out there in the wild west right now.
So that might be a reason why you want to
do both, yeah.
OK.
So another question is, often time when we're
designing these types of databases, the queries
themselves are not necessarily known ahead
of time.
And often, we want to design these databases
in order to optimize the query response.
But without knowing the queries, or if we're
trying to support sort of an exploratory set
of data and queries in that nature, it's very
difficult to know ahead of time which type
of database we should be using, what type
of data schema we should be using.
Are there any approaches, for instance, that
take a hybrid approach, where data actually
goes into multiple different types of databases
simultaneously?
Actually another excellent question.
OK, so the first answer I want to give you
there, actually, is something I didn't cover.
Maybe I should have.
Maybe we can do it in the future.
It's this notion of polystores.
It's still, I would say, more in the computer
science community.
So poly as in P-O-L-Y store.
And polystore idea is exactly what you're
saying, where people are realizing that, here's
an application that I'm interested in, but
this application has different kinds of data
that are all related to that application.
And the different kind could mean some of
it is structured, [INAUDIBLE] structured.
Other of it is, I'm not quite sure what the
structure is.
But another piece of it may be a graph I actually
derive.
So imagine this situation.
I might have text, and I might process the
text to derive a graph out of it.
Maybe it's a graph of all the people in that
text and the connections among the people.
But I want to keep both.
I want to keep the text of it, but I also
want to keep derived graph of it.
So the graph might actually go into a graph
database.
The text might just stay in some system that
does indexing of the text, and you might also
have structured.
So in computer science, and there are some
startup companies I'm aware of that are now
beginning to do this kind of thing, saying,
let's invent a polystore and, in a way, try
to take the responsibility from the user and
put it in the system.
So right now, I don't think that part is there
yet.
Right now, the user still has to say, well,
this is a graph, and that's the text, and
this is that, and I want you to manage all
of these.
But people are also looking at things like,
maybe the same data could be in multiple representations.
And also, maybe the system can decide at what
point can it go from one to the other.
But until that happens-- so that's one technology
that's coming.
You might want to look for it.
The other way to do it is actually to use
the semi-structured.
And all I've heard is just look out.
I think you'll find increasingly more vendors
providing more support for semi-structured
data.
So in a semi-structured world, you can certainly
have a structured part of it.
You can just say, well, that part of it is
fixed, right?
And this other part is variable.
So you could use a semi-structured model to
do that.
OK.
So I think we have time for one more question,
which is, so one of the interesting things,
at least in the biomedical space, is about
scientific reproducibility.
And could you speak to the provenance of the
data, particularly in terms of the translational
data processes that a database may support?
Yes.
And I actually think a lot of work has gone
on in computer science research about this
notion of provenance.
By the way, I think there are even-- at least
workshop, I don't think conference-- that
I've talked about provenance big data.
But as you can imagine, though, not only do
you have this little itty-bitty piece of data
that you care about, but if you kept its provenance,
the provenance can be huge, compared to the
data that you have.
So people are already starting to worry about,
what's the explosion that's going to happen
in the amount of data to start keeping the
provenance of it.
What we don't have yet, I believe, is good
systems, software systems or products that
do a good job.
I mean, there are certainly products that
are trying to help in that way.
I don't think it's zero.
But I think that part of it is just beginning
to happen.
So I think something a lot more systematic
in software systems need to be available so
that every one of us could be using provenance
with our data.
I'm just thinking about, in the computer science
world, there is a lot of research.
Here's one example.
So even when you run an SQL query, a very
structured database-- SQL is a structured
language-- you get a result back.
And for those of you who are familiar with
SQL, you have joins, right?
So I'm going to have lots of joins going on
and things like this.
And you get a result back, and a lot of times,
you might want to say, well, how did this
particular row appear in this result set?
I wasn't expecting it.
So people are actually looking at actually
the provenance of individual rows in the query
of a relational database, which actually itself
turns out to be quite an interesting challenging
problem.
Because you really should be able to click
on it and say, tell me how this came in.
And the system should be able to say, well,
this came in because I joined that with this,
and we selected this one over there, and there's
[INAUDIBLE] up here.
So these are all beginning to happen, and
there's just going to be even more data.
And also, there's a recent paper somebody
just sent me about why all of this is actually
going to end up becoming a big computational
burden, as well.
OK.
So I think we're out of time.
So thank you again so much for this wonderful
talk.
We're getting a lot of positive feedback already
from the attendees, and we'll end it here.
Thank you.
All right.
Great.
Thanks.
Very glad to be with you.